what's going on guys we're here to talk
about the whole new huawei mate pad
family as you can see in front of me we
got all the tablets here
i got the pro the big boy the big daddy
in front of me i've been using this for
the past couple weeks and i'm here to
answer some questions because i know a
lot of you out there looking for a
tablet possibly for the holiday season
or maybe to go back to school with or
maybe just to have around the house to
have some fun with but and you know
huawei makes some really nice tablets
but you know look we all know elephant
in the room there's are there are some
restrictions out there when it comes to
putting apps on huawei products so a lot
of people are scared or they're
apprehensive to get into something like
this because they're like well if i want
to put my banking apps on if i want to
put like youtube or video um apps or
watching like netflix or disney plus can
i do it on these mapads and the answer
is for the most part yes you can so i'm
going to walk you through some of the
steps you can actually do to get most of
these apps on the huawei mate pad and
i'll do it right here with the pro so
with that let's get down to it
[Music]
all right i'm going to put these on the
side here for the second because i'm
going to work on the maypad pro for the
most part because i'm used to this size
i've been using this for the past couple
weeks by the way all these mapads are
running uh huawei's new operating system
harmony os they've been developing this
for quite some time it is very nice to
use very user friendly um it resembles
some other os's that we know out there
so there is that the familiarity that's
in harmony os
but the speed and the efficiency within
it is very impressive okay so now let's
uh talk about
the big boy the pro the 2560 by 1600
resolution on the display it's a very
nice display it's a high frame rate on
this i think it's 120 hertz thereabouts
everything is very smooth very fluid on
this and the design of this made paddle
in the pro is really sweet look at this
it is thin it is very nice and it's a
widescreen
design so it's actually meant to be held
wide so of course you can go portrait
mode on this and i would probably do
this if i'm using it for let's say web
browsing or reading an article or a blog
or some documents let's say microsoft
word documents which you can do as well
but if i'm just consuming content you
know youtube videos netflix disney plus
et cetera et cetera i'm gonna go a
landscape on this and the keyboard as
you can tell is actually designed for
that now it's magnetic on the back of it
and you have two positions on the
keyboard one that's more upright ones
more angular of course you can also flip
it around and just go completely flat if
you'd like to do that as well if you
want to draw something or you want to be
a little bit more creative with it and
the keys the keyboard is very nice i got
a lot of emails coming in on this thing
i don't know what's going on here today
but a lot's happening um i'm actually
using the tablet guys it's not just for
show i actually using it but the key
travel on this is really good and i love
the width of the keyboard so everything
feels very comfortable very ergonomic so
if i'm banging out emails or writing on
documents i have no issues at all with
this i wasn't expecting it to be this
good to be frank with you all right
you're probably thinking to yourself
bobby great
sounds good on specs looks great but i
need to put apps on the thing can i put
apps on it
yes i'm going to walk you through a
couple ways to do that right now so
let's get into it let's start loading
apps on this thing now i already have
some apps already you can see here if i
go through
some of the app layout i've got adobe
photoshop i've got lightroom i've got
instagram facebook i tried youtube
studio unfortunately you can only go
web-based on this right now with that so
i'm gonna just delete that one right off
very easy to do hold it down uninstall
you're good to go i've got youtube
advanced which is a great alternative
for youtube out there so it actually is
all the youtube content video you can
actually sign in with your google id to
this and you can play it in the
background you can you know extract the
window move it around the your desktop
wherever you want it to be so it's a
really nice app as a matter of fact a
lot of people were recommending me this
because i'm on youtube quite a bit
especially here for the channel we have
to monitor our youtube channel to see
you know who likes our videos by the way
please like and subscribe to the channel
if you haven't done so already because
it does help us out a lot especially
this video thank you very much
but i got telegram on here whatsapp
tiktok there's a lot microsoft word and
i'm going to show you some other apps we
can put on here as well so one way to do
it is going to the huawei app gallery
now let's uh go on to that right here
and receive notifications i'm not a big
fan of notifications so they've got
their gaming here uh
they have different categorizations new
apps we love new games we love et cetera
et cetera you can go into searching for
games for apps as well
and there's a lot of apps actually in
this app gallery you would be surprised
at how much there is and i mean for here
in singapore because we use obviously
our sync pass our banking apps etc etc
these are all here for the most part so
we're not going to be missing a beat on
that and if something's not here there's
another way where you can pull the apps
from and i'll show you that just a
second yeah let's go through this so
like right here in singapore for example
sync pass right or it's our local id we
can have that logged into our the system
so we need to pull up our taxes or our
car registration and pay for things
online if we get a speeding ticket we
got to pay we can do it through sync
pass so on some of the apps will be
portrayable because they're designed for
phones so that will be something you
will have to turn around and do
so that just varies okay i mean you're
this is something that you'll notice and
this happens with some apps out there
because they are developed they're not
designed for tablets they're designed
for phones it's just part and parcel of
what we do right and we'll go back into
this and it goes back into landscape
mode but let's also go back into the app
gallery for a second here because now
i've got that
let's say you want to do some banking
right now here in singapore we got a few
different banks dbs is one you just
press that button right there digibank
so this is all designed to be used on
huawei products okay because huawei
products are very popular here in
singapore so this is something that all
the banking institutions wanted to do
there we go okay
you can allow to make calls allow all
using allow okay
so it'll say on here with the absence of
google services on your device banking
services on the app will be affected
push notification alerts or nearest atm
so you can't use that because it would
tie into google maps et cetera et cetera
but that's fine not a big deal let's
talk about
spotify right we gotta listen to music
right
now we've got spotify light and spotify
for artists what's interesting here is
that spotify is not available on the
huawei app gallery but there's a list of
various different options and from pedal
search what is pedal search pedal search
is sort of a search engine for apps for
android apps they're about and there are
you know files under apks because that's
the file name for any android app that
you want to put on your device and the
cool thing about android products is you
can actually side load apps you don't
have to go through a google play store
you can actually download it from you
know even though companies own websites
for that matter so that's what allows
you to do a search for those apps and
you can download it accordingly so
anyway um we're gonna go to spotify
light here and we're gonna install that
now as you can see it's gonna pull from
a site called apkpure.com
there's the app it'll say do you want to
download this you click on download it
will actually download the apk to your
device once it's done it'll say okay no
threats found install it installs it
and there you go
then you can
log in sign up and you've got spotify on
your device simple as that
what about
netflix
we need netflix in our lives right
yes we do
okay again netflix
takes me down to the website pulls it up
there's the apk it's automatically
downloading this
it lets you know that it's downloading
it as well now this is quite a large
file 115 megabytes so it's going to take
a little bit a couple seconds to
download it once it's done boom no fret
no threats found as you can see how fast
this is actually going on this that's
how quick it is to install apps on this
so it's almost like doing it from the
google play store or any even the
huawei's app gallery except it's just
going through peda search for this and
you can get started right there
you got full netflix what about disney
plus we're all in disney plus right you
know a lot of marvel tv shows out there
right now we gotta find our marvel shows
we just not can't we can't be left
without that right notification to
download it look how fast we're going on
this so see how quick it is to actually
get a lot of things on this is quite
impressive so you're not really missing
a beat for a lot of the content you're
going to get out there now what do you
say what about email for example what
about gmail or etc like that well
i actually use microsoft outlook for the
most part and i just log in with my
gmail account
and i have full access to my gmail all
my emails and everything else like that
plus i actually like the outlook app of
this matter because it includes calendar
includes everything i need inside of it
it's very organized i just i've liked it
even on other devices that i've used in
the past so not just on this but i've
liked outlook as well but here just in
case you're wondering disney plus
simple as that let me show you what
outlook looks like on here as a matter
of fact so i've got my my gmail right
here but as you can see i've got all my
stuff there i've got my junk drafts sent
deleted all that kind of stuff here also
got my geek culture email as well then i
can go in the calendar and see what's
going to go on today all my different
meetings shoots coming up all that is
here on the calendar so as you can tell
this is very nice very intuitive so if
you're worried about gmail you don't
need to use the gmail app sometimes the
gmail app is good for some things but
actually i like outlook for a lot of
other things as well plus it ties into
microsoft office which you can also get
here on this case in point for a lot of
you don't know you're going to think
well can you watch youtube videos and
the answer is yes you can through
youtube advanced so what is youtube
vance exactly well in my terminology i'm
going to call it like a shell that
encapsulates youtube inside of it so you
can log in with your google id there is
a way to do this though let me kind of
show you this as well i want to add
account now i'm showing on the screen
here it'll say an app on your device is
trying to sign into google account if
this was intentionally use sign in or
huawei if you have a device with this
brand button to connect to google sign
in page if not press cancel to go back
to the application that caused this
dialog to show up okay now a lot of
people will want to press on sign in
and actually will come up and say that
the cert you cannot do that
what you do is you press
click on huawei
establishes the link sign in with your
google account and then you are good to
go
that's how you sign into youtube
advanced just in case you're wondering i
don't want to already have signed into
it so
don't need to sign into it again but
that's how it works but as you can tell
here
i've got all the videos
you know recommendations from youtube um
you know based on the content that i
like to watch and the cool thing about
vance is it actually almost acts like
premium in a lot of ways now i pay for
premium myself but this does in a sense
that it does block ads and it does block
certain things and you can also play
youtube in the background on your tablet
so let's say you want to you know listen
to some
music or you know listen to a podcast or
that's on youtube but you want to do
some work as well you can actually do
that case in point let me just uh let's
go to geek culture real quick so example
if i want to let's say click on our
something just dropped in the studio
good volume on the tablet by the way
right
as you can tell this is sharp looks
great
got all the information here
then if i want to move around with this
it's playing in the background as you
can see the windows here so i can move
this around as i'm watching myself then
but let's say i want to go to my you
know microsoft word
i want to type out a document
i can do that
so there you go then we want to turn the
volume back up on the video actually
here razor's up on the front here you
got your n95 filters and all that
information here and on the back it does
walk you through about this i can bring
it back to the youtube i want uh the
straps the light pause it and then if i
just want to get rid of youtube then i
can as well and
we're back at it so
there you go there's a lot of
multitasking you can do with the youtube
advanced on that regard so if you're
worried about youtube do not be so we've
covered spotify we've covered netflix
we've covered disney plus we have
covered uh microsoft office we have
covered
you know youtube i mean what else do you
want to know we can go through this all
day long folks we covered banking apps
facebook facebook is there too
i've got uh
facebook right there notifications all
that great stuff
everything is there let's go to
lightroom you want to see how adobe
lightroom works
here
you got it all takes a moment to load up
because i got about 15 000 photos in my
lightroom
it's crazy but yes
take a look you can do full editing
capability
i downloaded this from petasearch so you
can have you can have adobe products on
this as well so if you're a content
creator like me you can use this you can
share your edits share with the
community you can do crops you can do
all this stuff everything is available
on this so now that i've just showed you
how to load apps here on the map pro
let's talk about the mapat family now
there is a made pad for everyone as
huawei likes to say so let's go through
it we got a 10.4 inch a 10.8 inch an 11
inch and a
12.6 inch okay that's the big boy that
i've been using for this entire review
let's go to 10.4 this is going to be for
that maybe that more novice tablet user
it's small it's lightweight it's compact
something to keep around the house if
you've got small kids around there and
you want them to have access to a tablet
maybe you want to keep them entertained
while you're doing some work because a
lot of the parents are working from home
now this might be a good tablet for you
we move on to the 10.8 the 10.8 oddly
enough is more expensive than the 11 and
i'll tell you why the 10.8 comes in at
998 dollars singapore dollars mind you
reason being this is a snap a dragon 870
in this the 11 has a snapdragon 865 it's
a newer processor hence it will be more
expensive 998 for this 10.8 inches also
a great size tablet to have so the 10
pointer will be more for those out there
that want to you know want a faster
processor when i you know access some
more pro applications multitasking
you're going to need this also has a
nice camera right here in the corners
you can see right there for some selfie
camera action like that and also if you
want to go into landscape mode it's
right there in the corner as well i
actually like the camera placement here
because this is an area that you're
going to be looking at when you're doing
the tablet and it makes more sense to me
personally so i like it there okay
moving on to the 11 inch now this is
only slightly larger than the 10.8 but
it does come at a price point of 698
singapore dollars reason as i just
mentioned the snapdragon 865 versus the
snapdragon 870 on this now you do have
the camera here it is in the center and
it's in the bezel very small very
compact
it's incognito but again you're not
going to get the same performance as the
10.8 there is a difference but for
day-to-day tasks you're not going to
really notice much okay now we move on
to the big boys i've been talking about
this entire video the 12.6 inch the pro
this comes in at 1 398 singapore dollars
you've got the care 9000 9000e processor
in this you've got the higher resolution
display you've got all the bells and
whistles in this bad boy the great
camera setup on the front and back on
this this is a really nice tablet i've
enjoyed using this the entire time i've
been testing this out but again this may
be more expensive for some users out
there so
10.8 or the 11 or even the 10.4 will be
a great option for you guys out there
just depends on what you need the tablet
for anyway those are my thoughts and to
introduce to you to the maypad family
let me know your thoughts in the
comments section below any questions you
have on using these mate pads i'll try
to do my best to answer them for you
with that follow us on facebook
subscribe to us on youtube like this
video it helps out our channel a lot
take care stay safe and i'll chat to you
soon bye